la période des vacances reste le moment
idéal pour entretenir les soixante dix
sept collèges publics du département
depuis novembre 2015
au collège de montgaillard toutes les
clôtures ont été rénovés ramallah proche
de la rondelle est vrai personnage
négatif est inquiet donc là on n'a rien
sur les champs le chantier sur une
partie donc vous dire que si un chef de
chantier à ce monde alors monsieur en
face que nous intéresserait nous c'est
que vous ouvrez votre zone de chantier
qui ne soit pas visible des élèves on va
dire les choses comme ça peut être le
fait que voilà peut-être que c'est plus
simple pour vous c'est à dire que ce
soit fermer un établissement qui est
vieux de quand même de plus de 40 ans
puisque ni de 1972
donc c'est normal qu'ils les travaux
d'ampleur à réaliser pour cela nous
remercions la collectivité territoriale
de réaliser ces travaux qui sont
essentiels mais je veux doivent veiller
à ce que les élèves travaillent dans nos
bonnes des élèves et les personnels
soient dans de bonnes conditions
une communication de terrain efficace
afin de trouver la meilleure des
solutions pour ces entreprises locales
mobilisés dans toute l'île par le
département
cette volonté de réhabiliter son
patrimoine non seulement participe
également au développement économique de
l'île parce que nous travaillons en
concert en concertation avec le monde du
btp avec les artisans et pour cette
année 2016 nous avons 14 14 collèges qui
vont bénéficier d'une réhabilitation
assez lourde 2d des façades de des
clôtures surtout pour un montant de 7
millions d'euros
justin pour 14 collèges cette année et
nous avons mis en place également un
plan pluriannuel d'investissement qui
avait mené par notre élue déléguée le
tour des quatre recteur de cet
établissement de 1200 élèves est aussi
l'occasion d'échanger avec cette équipe
éducative
nous avons des jeunes très qualifiés ils
sont vraiment ils en veulent et ils nous
département nous allons mettre tout en
oeuvre pour qu'ils puissent arriver dans
de bonnes conditions
soixante deux mille élèves sur toute
l'île cette population collégiennes ont
pleine croissance doit trouver le
meilleur des cadre d'épanouissement